>> Laura: A WELL-KNOWN PRIEST
WHO HAS ALSO SERVED AS THE
NATIONAL COCHAIR OF PRO-LIFE
VOICES FOR TRUMP HAS BEEN KICKED
OUT OF THE PRIESTHOOD BY
POPE FRANCIS.
THE VATICAN SAID THE DECISION TO
REMOVE FRANK PAVONE WAS DUE TO
HIS BLASPHEMOUS SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS WHERE PAVONE REFERRED TO
SUPPORTERS OF THIS LOSER BIDEN
AND IS MORALLY CORRUPT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE SHOCKING MOVE ON THE PART OF
THE POPE IS MADE ALL THE MORE
REMARKABLE DUE TO THE
ALLEGATIONS OF AND FINANCIAL
DEVIANCY FROM TOP VATICAN
OFFICIALS.
SPEED REMAINS DEFIANT, STILL
CALLING HIMSELF FATHER AND
CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE MASS SINCE
THE EXCOMMUNICATION.
JOINING ME NOW, FATHER FRANK
PAVONE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT TIME FOR
YOU.
YOU SAID YOU LEARNED THIS FROM A
NEWS AGENCY.
HAVE YOU BEEN FORMALLY NOTIFIED
BY THE VATICAN?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE CULMINATION
OF 21 YEARS OF ABUSE BY CHURCH
AUTHORITIES TO ME INTO MY
MINISTRY DESPITE THE FACT THAT
WE HELP THE VATICAN.
WE HELP RUN SOME OF THE
OPERATIONS OUT OF THE POPE'S
MISSION TO THE UNITED NATIONS.
WE HELP THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WITH INTERNATIONAL PRO-LIFE
ISSUES, WE RUN THE LARGEST
MINISTRY FOR HEALING AFTER
ABORTION WHICH POPE FRANCIS HAS
PERSONALLY ENCOURAGED ME TO KEEP
GOING ON.
WE DO OTHER PRO-LIFE WORK WITH
WHICH MANY OF OUR VIEWERS ARE
FAMILIAR.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
A LOT OF IT OBVIOUSLY IS
CONNECTED WITH THE
CANCEL CULTURE THAT COMES
AGAINST SUPPORTERS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CRITICS OF
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
WE ARE ONLY GOING TO GET LOUDER
ABOUT IT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE SILENCED.
THIS IS AN EFFORT, NOT JUST AN
EFFORT TO SILENCE ME BUT TO SO
MANY OF US.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS, AS
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THEY STAND FOR
THEIR CONSERVATIVE VALUES.
THEY STAND UP FOR THEIR
CONTENTS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO THE SAME
WITHIN THE CHURCH TO PRIEST LIKE
ME.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA POST IS JUST AN
EXCUSE.
THEY'VE GIVEN ME 21 YEARS OF
EXCUSES.
IT'S ALWAYS SHIFTING SAND,
ALWAYS CHANGING GOALPOSTS.
AS YOU CAN WELL APPRECIATE.
>> Laura: LET ME ASK YOU ONE
QUESTION, FATHER PAVONE.
WE WERE ASKED AT ONE POINT TO
BECOME A PARISH PRIEST AND YOU
DECLINED.
DID THAT OCCUR?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S HOW THIS STARTED.
THE REASON I SAY 21 YEARS.
IN 2001, AFTER I LEAD PRIESTS
FOR LIFE.
HE SAID I WANT YOU TO DO PARISH
WORK.
THERE'S A UPROAR FROM THE
PEOPLE.
NOT ONLY AN OBJECTION FOR ME.
HIS OFFICE GOT INUNDATED.
IT WAS A FRACTION OF THE SIZE
THAT WE ARE NOW.
PEOPLE SAID WHY CAN'T A PRIEST
DEVOTE HIMSELF FULL-TIME TO
DEFENDING THE UNBORN AND ENDING
ABORTION?
I'M CONVINCED THAT'S PART OF MY
VOCATION.
MY VOCATION IS TO BE A PRIEST
AND BE A FULL-TIME PRO-LIFE
LEADER AND I DON'T INTEND.
>> Laura: BUT AS A PRIEST,
FATHER PAVONE, YOU HAVE TO GO
WHERE THE CHURCH TELLS YOU TO
GO, CORRECT?
I KNOW A LOT OF PRIEST WHO DID
WANT TO CHANGE PARISHES BUT THEY
WERE TOLD THEY HAD TO GO TO
INNER-CITY PARISH.
WE DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
MINUTIA BECAUSE IT'S CONFUSING
THAT I HAVE TO ASK ONE QUESTION.
YOU SAY THAT YOU WANT TO APPEAL
THIS.
THEY SAY THERE IS NO APPEAL
PROCESS FOR WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> IF THE PULP SIGNS OFF ON
SOMETHING, WHAT THEY MEAN IS
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE CHURCH
ABOVE THE POPE.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S NO WAY
TO CHANGE IT.
THE POPE CAN REVERSE IT, THE
NEXT POPE CAN REVERSE IT.
THE PEOPLE, AND I AM APPEALING
TO THE PEOPLE OF GOD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH US AND SHOWING
SUPPORT FOR THIS WORK OF SAVING
LIVES AND HEALING HEARTS.
IF THE POPE CLOSES THE DOOR ON
ME, I'M GOING TO BE RIGHT THERE
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE DOOR
WAITING FOR IT TO OPEN AGAIN.
I'M NOT GOING TO A DIFFERENT
CHURCH.
I'M A LOYAL CATHOLIC, LOYAL
PRIEST.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO LAST.
THIS IS AGAINST ALL OF US.
IT'S TO CANCEL CULTURE IN THE
CHURCH.
IT'S GOT TO BE EXPOSED AND IT'S
GOT TO BE RESISTED.
>> Laura: MEANWHILE FATHER
JAMES MARTIN GETS MEETINGS WITH
THE POPE.
OBVIOUSLY FAIRLY RADICAL GUY.
NO PROBLEM